my name is Brook Watson I work at a
company called eco Health Alliance you
may have heard of it
before I work with gnome I do in fact
have a snake who is much cuter than his
it's not a rivalry it's fine her name is
Judith she's right there she's very
wonderful but I'm not gonna spend too
much and I also should say that I am
often the beneficiary of gnomes
excellent data packages so they've been
super useful in my analysis process but
I'm not gonna spend too much time
talking about eco health because today
I'm talking about a sort of side project
that is an hour package that I created
that is has just one function it's
pretty playful you know fun package that
I hope you guys find useful but also
kind of bring some delight into your
workflows but I also think that it
serves as a powerful metaphor for the
ways that we think about learning both
individually and in community and the
ways that one can move from an R user to
an hour developer if that is something
that you want to do so the package is
called Bert
but I realized yesterday that I had
never said this name out loud because
obviously I'm creating the package
online and that with my accent it
doesn't really come out right it's
supposed to be pronounced like this
though I would also accept this the
first sound is by a very wonderful
gentleman called gucci mane and the
second is Birdman and this package is
available on github so you can download
it front using dev tools and it has
exactly one function again a function
that I find hard to pronounce and it
plays a short sound when it is called so
if you are wondering how to pronounce
the function name and the my walk-on
song wasn't familiar to you this might
be helpful so that's the function and
basically it's an alarm it's like a
kitchen timer for your code so the use
case for birds that I often find myself
running sort of two to ten minute jobs
these aren't the long scripts that
you're leaving running overnight and
then going home and praying that they're
working in the morning these are the
really quick ones that are long enough
for you to be able to move away from
your code for some period of time but
that are short enough that you don't
want to dive into emails for the rest of
the afternoon
so you might want to be reminded that
something is going on over in the
background and if you want to do that
audibly you can use burr so this is an
example of maybe you want to update all
of your packages that takes kind of
awhile you don't know how long it will
take you can use scrap and
and flavor flav can tell you when your
script is done or a little join can or
birdman can so sometimes you want to use
this to celebrate that you are done
running a simulation but sometimes you
might want to use it to alert yourself
to the fact that something has gone
wrong so i often use them in functions
usually only functions that I'm sharing
with myself unless you warn your
co-workers or you're pranking your
co-workers to kind of use cases so this
function when it's called on a new on
one will just run no problems but if
it's called on the character dj khaled
will tell you that something is amiss
you can also use this to help increase
the level of testing that you do so I
have only recently started improving by
practices around using things like the
assert that package to do unit tests to
make sure that everything is running in
the ways that it should and this sort of
goes hand-in-hand with what Emily
Robinson was saying earlier about
creating reproducible examples sometimes
breaking things down to the smallest
size and reminding yourself that the
world is working the way that it should
be at least on that small scale is
really valuable so you might want to
include four in two different two
different sounds one might be positive
so without burn in this fungus in this
script you could just you would get a
true when you need to and you would get
a false when things aren't equal so with
it you get and if you if something's
going wrong and you need to hold up you
can be told to hold up so there are 51
songs right now in the pack or clips
they're not quite songs right now in the
package they are they can be called
numerically or they can be called by
their
name which are there's some sort of
naming convention based on various
artist names and if some artist is not
included you'll get a random sound so I
recognize that if you are a person who
cares about these things I may have
neglected your favorite artist and I
recognize that this is a very limited
list even though it's 51 people I only
have one of the three amigos it's not
even the best Mego was take off so I
might have left something out and if
that's the case then you can fork to
this and github and submit a pull
request or make your own package and so
that sort of brings me to the making of
this package that's the it's a one
function in the entire package but
there's kind of a back story behind it
that I think says something more about
the ways that we contribute in this open
source community so the mother of ber is
a package called beeper that is very
perfect and delightful in its own right
that many of you may use heard some
audible cheers it's very wonderful
beeper was created by this guy Rasmus
Baath and it plays small sounds most
many video game sounds so if you want to
celebrate the end of a code you might
run
right so already perfect it does it
can't be improved upon can it so I
immediately shared this with my
co-workers and immediately drove into a
conversation about how we could add
different sounds and beeper does include
functionality to include a URL as the
function argument to a wave path if you
have like a WAV file that's on the
internet you can play that and it will
play that sound it can play a whole song
if you like there's also like Spotify
like you can have other song players but
you could play songs in our so we also a
co-worker and I really like a website
called the rat board that has all these
ad-libs that I pulled from this is again
a photo photo of gucci mane who had a
very inspirational glow up season last
year and who inspired much of this
package and so if these files had
existed in wave form on the rat board
calm this probably would have been the
end of the story we would have played
them and had a little bit of fun and it
would have been great but because they
did it and because I sort of had a hook
in my brain that was like really focused
on fixing this problem that sent me down
a rabbit hole of trying to get these
audio files in wave form so I started
out trying to scrape them from the
website using a hitter and our vest
packages which are really helpful for
scraping HTML web pages but this website
isn't in HTML it's in JavaScript
primarily so I had to convert that from
Java I don't know any JavaScript and all
the HTML and CSS I know is things that I
learned when I was in the seventh grade
because I wanted my myspace to look cool
so so but these are all things that I
was able to scrap together as I was
making this because I was really engaged
in the process and by the time I had all
of that data which involves a lot of
sort of cleaning names with stringer and
other tidy verse packages I had done a
lot of work and wanted to wrap it up
into a package with dev tools and the
final step in the process was sharing it
with the community so it's on github I
tweeted about
it I talked about it in with our ladies
community and which again is something
that Emily discussed earlier and that
many of you are members of and many of
you are familiar with and this is my
like my personal community there are a
lot of other like really supportive our
communities in New York as many people
have mentioned is a really sort of
welcoming environment and so I think I
think there's an old sort of patriarchal
sentence that we all know like phrase
that we all know and love that behind
every man behind every successful man is
a woman right we've all heard that for
that sentence but I think a more
appropriate sentence is that behind
every successful woman is like ten other
people hyping her up in the Our Lady
slack because that's really been my
experience and so all this has really
led me to develop these thoughts about
how one can become an open-source
contributor and a developer of our
packages and this is just one way this
is obviously a kind of a toy example but
I think it's really useful in thinking
about the ways that we can take things
apart and learn from them and put them
back together if it's something that
we're interested in
I don't really particularly care about
JavaScript but I learned a lot about it
because I wanted to use it to make
something that I thought would be fun
and that I thought like I could share
with my friends so just a reminder well
I think you we often start by copying
something that exists right you copy the
code of somebody who you admire you take
a script that you don't understand and
you start pulling it apart we do this
from childhood we look this is how we
learn how to draw how we learn how to do
math and we start by copying and once we
copy enough times we can learn how to
start adding things that we like and
often we mess it up and in the process
that creates something new
and often we intentionally just continue
to add more layers until something has
we have created a new
and this is like the nature the
fundamental nature of remixes right it's
taking something that is rooted in a
tradition and adding the new generation
that is now learning about and adding
their contributions to that tradition
so copying is like not a great doesn't
have a great reputation especially in
sort of academic worlds we don't think
that this is something we should be
bragging about that we often want to say
that what we made is our own but we know
that that's not the case and everyone is
influenced by other people and I think
there are important distinctions between
good copying and bad copying or good
good theft and bad theft so good copying
takes from many different people and
pulls from many different resources and
it honors and acknowledges and credits
the creators of those resources and it
is a platform for deep study so good
copying is sort of the taking a lawn
mower apart to understand how it works
and then put it back together it's
useful to a person in understanding the
way that systems are made and then in
the end it finally transforms and
remixes something into a new version so
as always Kanye has some deep thoughts
on this as well that he shared recently
and I think we think of Kanye West as
someone who's really original and who
has made a lot of new popularized a lot
of new kinds of music and has done a lot
of really sort of avant-garde things in
his art and in that he is constantly
talking about his influences and he's
constantly reaching from different areas
and pulling fashion and music and all
kinds of different things together in
making something new and so I think when
we think about originality what we're
not thinking about starting making
something new from scratch we're
thinking about pulling different areas
together to
combined whether that's combining
different styles of music or using our
tools to make a music thing any way that
you want it to sort of like remix
something that's what it's about making
those diagonal connections and so as
always I'm shocked that I'm the first
person to have an xkcd slide today but
as always xkcd says it better than I can
when you take something from somebody
who influences you in the open source
community you're not taking it from them
you're when you're copying something you
make to of that thing and so I think
this is a really helpful framework when
we're thinking about building from
others and learning from others and
contributing to to this community so I
really enjoyed this I don't consider
myself as a developer first I consider
myself sort of more of a an analyst and
a scientist but this is a really fun way
for me to get involved as someone who
doesn't have a computer science
background doesn't doesn't meet all of
the tech check boxes I think if anything
what I want folks to take away from this
talk is that the barrier to entry is
much lower than it might seem so that's
about all I've got that if you want to
sort of go back to these slides they're
on my github I also have written up a
blog post that goes into more detail
about sort of a code line by line how I
got these audio files how I made them
into a package it's been a really fun
process for me and I think like if
anybody is interested in trying to get
started in this and doesn't feel as
though they're a developer this is
something that they want to convert done
before I'm more than happy to talk to
folks I think it's something I would
really want to encourage also Judy does
have an Instagram she is open to
sponsored content
brand partnerships you guys can reach
out she's got a fresh nineteen followers
maybe so that's my job
[Applause]
you